Німці люблять випити.
Тож коли я переїхала сюди два роки тому, я чекала найгіршого!
Але! З'ясувалося: ті, хто більше за всіх п'ють, навчилися найкраще переробляти пластикові пляшки.
Майже 99% пляшок ідуть на переробку.
Я думаю, що ресайклінг дуже важливий.
Так, я вже вчу цьому свою дитину.
Німеччина - це справді історія успіху.
Саме пляшки - одні з найбільших забруднювачів довкілля, з якими всі країни намагаються боротися.
Німеччина, здається, знає як. То ж чому решта держав не роблять так само?
У когось є проблеми, у інших - виправдання.
Можливо, є вихід з глобальної пластикової кризи?
Страшна пластикова пляшка.
Символ нашого катастрофічного впливу на планету.
І все дійсно гірше нікуди. Щодня у світі продається майже 1,5 мільярда пластикових пляшок!
А Німеччина створила систему боротьби з ними.
Система називається Pfand, це загальний термін.
Генрієтте Шнайдер представляє Німецьку організацію з допомоги довкіллю,
яка вивчає та підтримує Pfand, тобто систему застави й обміну пластику і скла.
Сама по собі ця система працює дуже добре.
У навколишньому середовищі майже не залишається упаковок від напоїв,
і в природу майже не потрапляють нові.
Це дійсно добре.
Аби захистити довкілля від забруднення, німецький уряд запровадив систему застави за пляшки в 2003 році.
Ще одна мета - підштовхнути виробників пакування для напоїв до турботи про природу.
Ось як працює система: виробники виготовляють пляшку, а в її вартість закладають заставу.
Пляшку продають оптовим або роздрібним торговцям, а ті продають її споживачеві.
Коли споживачі допили свої напої...
Час повертати гроші!
Пляшки несуть назад до магазину. Або до одного із 48 тисяч автоматів обміну, які є в країні.
Це справді дуже важко! Треба перепочити.
Автомати приймають більшість видів пляшок.
Фее, так гидко.
Я багата!
За 25 зданих пляшок отримали приблизно три з половиною євро.
Люди здебільшого роблять це задля солодкої нагороди.
З пляшок, які здають в автомати, близько 40 відсотків - багаторазові.
Їх миють, наповнюють і знову продають.
Багаторазову пластикову пляшку в Німеччині можна використовувати до 20 разів, а скляну - до 50 разів.
Решта - це одноразові пляшки.
У їхній вартості застава врахована в подвійному розмірі, щоб споживачам не хотілося купувати таку тару.
Проблема з одноразовими пляшками полягає в тому, що їхня переробка вимагає великих затрат енергії.
До того ж, лише чверть пляшок знову стають тарою.
Решта переробляються на волокна або інший матеріал, експортуються або просто спалюються.
Навіть попри те, що багаторазові пляшки треба збирати, мити й транспортувати,
вуглецевий слід кожної одноразової пляшки вдвічі перевищує вуглецевий слід багаторазової за весь термін служби.
Депозитна система застави й обміну пляшок здебільшого спрацювала насамперед тому,
що до супермаркету чи магазину, де приймають пляшки, можна дійти за кілька хвилин.
А роздрібні торговці можуть на цьому заробити.
Ті, хто збирають пляшки, можуть обирати більш вигідний варіант:
переробляти їх самостійно або відправляти переробникам.
Одноразове пакування масово пішло у світ у 80-х і 90-х роках.
Тоді вважалося, що пластик стане легким замінником крихких скляних пляшок.
Згодом екологи почали бити на сполох.
Уряди різних країн намагалися пропонувати різні рішення.
Наприклад, зобов'язали виробників платити за переробку й маркувати тару так званими "зеленими крапками",
які означають, що виробник уже заплатив за її переробку.
Тодішній міністр довкілля Німеччини Юрґен Тріттін вирішив, що країні потрібні радикальніші кроки.
Попри супротив лобі виробників напоїв і судові позови, він запустив депозитну систему - Pfand.
Рішення Тріттіна так добре "зайшло", і він так ним пишався, що навіть називав себе DJ Dоsenpfand, тобто "діджей Застава".
Утім, більшість західних урядів досі не здатні дати відсіч корпораціям-виробникам напоїв.
Для них дешевше обирати дуже дешевий і легкий матеріал.
Сьогодні ціни на нафту досить низькі, пластик - легкий.
Тож корпорації платять лише за виробництво тари, на все інше їм начхати.
Джоан Марк Саймон та його колеги домагаються відповідальнішого поводження з відходами у світі.
Нині близько 20 країн, переважно в Європі, мають схожі системи застави й обміну.
Експериментують з депозитними системами й деякі штати в США та Австралії.
Інші країни, як-от Індонезія та Еквадор, випробували інші методи.
Зокрема - обмін пластикових пляшок на квитки на автобус.
Шотландія останньою запровадила систему застави й обміну тари після закликів з боку громадськості.
Парламент Великобританії теж майже ухвалив таке рішення, але згодом відклав його.
Критики в ЄС кажуть, що пластикове лобі все ще відіграє значну роль у гальмуванні таких рішень.
Ми бачимо, що вони виступають проти запровадження нових систем обміну й застави тари.
Є пропозиція від уряду прийняти закон про таку систему.
В ніч перед голосуванням міністру телефонують представники галузі, і пропозиція знімається, можливість втрачена.
Скандал із витоком внутрішніх документів Coca-Cola шокував світ:
компанія мала викладену на папері стратегію протидії системам застави за пластикові пляшки.
Недостатньо суворі правила поводження з відходами призвели до того, що чимало де можна побачити ось такі пейзажі.
Безумовно, корпорації скористалися цією можливістю,
і вони повністю відійшли від тих методів, які практикувалися раніше.
Сіддхарт Сінгх - дослідник з питань управління відходами в Нью-Делі.
Як і в багатьох інших країнах півдня, виробництво відходів в Індії набирає обертів.
Методи боротьби з цим формально є, але вони не здатні впоратися з усім сміттям, як би не намагалися.
Показники збору пластику насправді дуже високі.
Понад 90 відсотків сміття збирається.
Але проблема в тому, що відходи майже не сортуються.
Стихійні збирачі відходів відіграють велику роль у Південній та Південно-Східній Азії та Африці.
Коли вони відбирають пластик з несортованих відходів, він часто брудний і мало придатний для повторного використання.
Це означає, що його переробна цінність і обсяг, який можна переробити, знижуються.
Західні країни також часто експортують свої відходи до країн, що розвиваються, і це погіршує ситуацію.
У Німеччині вулиці чистіші, зокрема, й через систему застави й обігу.
Вона також дозволяє систематично збирати незабруднені відходи, які можна ефективно переробити.
Але чи допомогла Німеччині система Pfand перейти на більш "зелену" тару?
Дослідження показують, що з 2003 року частка пластикових багаторазових пляшок на ринку насправді значно зменшилася.
Одна з причин полягає в тому, що великі мережі супермаркетів і надалі віддають перевагу одноразовим пляшкам,
бо їх не потрібно повертати.
А ще виробники отримують прибутки від застави за пластик, закладеної в ціну, яку ніхто не вимагає назад.
Тож їм вигідніше виробляти дорожчу одноразову тару, за яку покупцеві доведеться заплатити більше.
Багато хто пропонує змінити таку систему.
Ефективним санкційним механізмом може бути, наприклад, збір у 20 центів на кожну одноразову упаковку для напоїв.
Податок, сплачений з кожної упаковки чи пляшки, міг би змусити корпорації переглянути свої стратегії.
Але дечому інші країни все ж можуть повчитися у Німеччини.
Варто зробити збір тари якомога більш універсальним.
У Німеччині, наприклад, супермаркети зобов’язані забирати все одноразове пакування, яке продають.
Крім того, сума застави, яку сплачує покупець, дійсно важлива, і вона відрізняється залежно від країни.
Це має бути сума, яка дійсно змусить споживача повернути тару й отримати назад гроші.
Країни півночі планети, зокрема й Німеччина, все ще виробляють набагато більше пакувальних відходів, ніж південні країни.
Тому найперше й найбільш екологічно доцільне рішення - це скорочення виробництва пластику.
На другому місці - багаторазове використання.
На третьому - переробка.
Щодо кожного окремого споживача, то можна носити власну пляшку з водою
і таким чином створювати менше відходів.
Звичайно, на державному рівні варто домагатися такої політики, як німецька,
адже це допомогло зменшити кількість пляшок і збільшити їхнє повторне використання.